as a national of an EU country you are
automatically an EU citizen EU
citizenship comes with lots of benefits
such as the right to move and reside
anywhere in the EU subject to certain
conditions
this means your home can be anywhere in
the EU
you can stay in any EU country for up to
three months all you need is a valid ID
card or passport in case you decide to
settle down for more than three months
then you simply need to register as a
resident the requirements will differ
depending on the country and on the
reason for your stay as a worker once
you have proof of employment you're free
to stay as long as you want as a job
seeker you can move to another EU
country for up to six months as a
pensioner you enjoy the right to live in
any EU country all you need is health
insurance and proof you have the means
to support yourself as a student the
same conditions apply as long as you are
enrolled at an approved school or
university your EU citizenship comes
with additional rights in fact your
family can join you in your new EU
country and you have the right to vote
and be a candidate for local and
European elections after five years of
legally residing in another EU country
you can apply for permanent residency
you are always at home in the EU